[Music]
language is endlessly variable each of
us can come up with an infinite number
of sentences in our native language and
we're able to do so from an early age
almost as soon as we start to
communicate in sentences how is this
possible in the early 1950s Noam Chomsky
proposed a theory based on the
observation that the key to this
versatility seems to be grammar the
familiar grammatical structure of an
unfamiliar sentence points us toward its
meaning he suggested that there are
grammatical rules that apply to all
languages and that the rules are innate
the human brain is hardwired to process
language according to these rules
he labelled this faculty universal
grammar and it launched lines of inquiry
that shaped both the field of
linguistics and the emerging field of
cognitive science for decades to come
Chomsky and other researchers set out to
investigate the two main components of
universal grammar first whether they're
far in fact grammar rules that are
universal to all languages and second
whether these rules are hardwired in the
brain in attempts to establish the
universal rules of grammar Chomsky
developed an analytical tool known as
generative syntax which represents the
order of words in a sentence in
hierarchical syntax trees that show what
structures are possible based on this
tree we could suggest a grammar rule
that adverbs must occur in verb phrases
but with more data it quickly becomes
clear that adverbs can appear outside of
verb phrases
this simplified example illustrates a
major problem it takes a lot of data
from each individual language to
establish the rules for that language
before we can even begin to determine
which rules all languages might have in
common
when Chomsky proposed universal grammar
many languages lacked the volume of
recorded samples necessary to analyze
them using generative syntax even with
lots of data mapping the structure of a
language is incredibly complex after 50
years of analysis we still haven't
completely figured out English as more
linguist data was gathered and analyzed
it became clear that languages around
the world
differ widely challenging the theory
that there were universal grammar rules
in the 1980s Chomsky revised his theory
in an attempt to accommodate this
variation according to his new
hypothesis of principles and parameters
all languages shared certain grammatical
principles but could vary in their
parameters or the application of these
principles for example a principle is
every sentence must have a subject but
the parameter of whether the subject
must be explicitly stated could vary
between languages the hypothesis of
principles and parameters still didn't
answer the question of which grammatical
principles are universal in the early
2000s constancy
that there's just one shared principle
called recursion which means structures
can be nested inside each other take
this sentence which embeds a sentence
within a sentence within a sentence or
this sentence which embeds a noun phrase
in a noun phrase in a noun phrase
recursion was a good candidate for a
universal grammar rule because it can
take many forms however in 2005
linguists published findings on an
Amazonian language called peat aha which
doesn't appear to have any recursive
structures so what about the other part
of Chomsky's theory that our language
faculty is innate when he first proposed
universal grammar the idea that there
was a genetically determined aspect of
language acquisition at a profound
revolutionary impact it challenged the
dominant paradigm called behaviorism
behaviorists argued that all animal and
human behaviors including language were
acquired from the outside by the mind
which starts out as a blank slate today
scientists agree that behaviorism was
wrong and there is underlying
genetically encoded biological machinery
for language learning many think the
same biology responsible for language is
also responsible for other aspects of
cognition so they disagree with chunkies
idea that there is a specific isolated
innate language faculty in the brain the
theory of universal grammar prompted the
documentation and study of many
languages that hadn't been studied
before it also caused an old idea to be
re-evaluated and eventually overthrown
to make room for our growing
understanding of the human brain
what would you guess is the most
difficult word to translate we bet it
isn't what you think
find out with this video
[Music]